[Music]
thank you
this is Sky News at 10 our top story the
international criminal court issues an
arrest warrant for Vladimir Putin over
war crimes including the Abduction of
children
it is forbidden by international law for
five powers to transfer civilians from
the territory they live in to other
territories
we have a special report on the
Ukrainian children being taken from
their homes and the parents doing
everything to get them back
also tonight the doctors and the
government to enter pay talks as it's
revealed NHS strikes this week lead to
more than 170 000 cancellations
more walkouts by airport staff and the
passport office planned for this Easter
passengers warned of severe delays
Paris Hilton tells Sky News she was
locked in a tiny cell and force-fed
medication in a facility for troubled
teenagers
they would force medication on everyone
so one time I I don't want to take these
anymore so I just kind of hid the pills
under my tongue and put them in a
Kleenex and then later on someone found
out and I got in so much trouble
[Music]
hundreds of arrests in France as
protests continue over president
macron's pension reforms
Prince Harry's libel case back in court
as the mail on Sunday's publisher sets
out its defense
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
foreign
it's a war that has devastated parts of
Ukraine scarring the people who live
there both physically and mentally for
many of the children who are growing up
during this conflict they will live with
the memory of the rest of their lives
and now the international criminal court
wants those responsible to face the
consequences issuing an arrest warrant
for the Russian President Vladimir Putin
and Russia's commissioner on children's
rights the court has accused them of war
crimes including the illegal deportation
of children to Russia something the
Kremlin has called outrageous and
unacceptable tonight we have a special
report from Ukraine where there are
claims that thousands of children have
been removed from their families but
first our International Affairs editor
Dominic Michonne has tonight's first
report
it is an extraordinary development in
this war Vladimir Putin the leader of a
U.N security Council permanent member
Nation facing an International arrest
warrant and for the most serious of war
crimes
Sky News was the first to reveal video
evidence of Russian soldiers searching a
place of sanctuary in Ukraine looking
for children this was one orphanage in
her son where orphans were abducted at
gunpoint by the Russian military
these children among thousands across
Ukraine said to have been taken by the
Russians during this war
allegations now the focus of
international criminal court arrest
warrants that go to the very top of the
Russian government their international
criminal court is issued Two Worlds of
arrest in the Eucharist situation
for Vladimir Putin president of the
Russian Federation and foreign
commissioner of the Russian presidents
from children's right for the alleged
war crimes of deportation of children
from Ukrainian occupied territories
entered the Russia Federation
it is forbidden by international law for
occupied powers to transfer civilians
from the territory they live in to other
territories this was Vladimir Putin
meeting his children's rights
commissioner last month the arrest
warrants against both for being welcomed
by Ukraine's president zielinski
separating children from their families
depriving them of any opportunity to
contact their relatives Hiding Children
on the territory of Russia throwing them
in remote regions all this is an obvious
State policy of Russia State decisions
and state evil which begins precisely
with the top official of this state
the warrants mean Vladimir Putin must
think very carefully about where he
travels and make the Russian leader even
more of an international Pariah the
Kremlin and its mouthpieces have reacted
with Fury
stupidity and irresponsibility of the
international
criminal court it's the policy of
Russian government to save children not
to steal children but to save children
from their Frontline Zone
so what are the chances of Vladimir
Putin going from wartime leader to the
accused in an international court of law
we have to be very realistic that we're
not going to see uh Putin in The Hague
anytime soon and of course there'll be a
lot of cynicism as to whether we will
ever see him there uh of course we won't
be looking at a trial In Absentia at the
ICC the move puts Putin in the dubious
company a former Libyan leader Muammar
Gaddafi and Sudanese president Omar
al-Bashir both indicted by the ICC but
never tried Vladimir Putin may be able
to elude prosecution for now but that
doesn't mean this move doesn't have real
significance it's important because this
man is now as many would say he should
have been said to be from a couple of
weeks after the war started labeled as a
criminal and that's going to be make it
much much more difficult for the
Coalition of countries supporting
Ukraine to separate out and to say oh we
shouldn't be carrying on with this war
next week China's president Xi Jinping
flies to Moscow for talks with Vladimir
Putin his host will be an alleged war
criminal how might that influence his
next move the answer to that could be
crucial in the next stage of this war
Dominic wagorn's Sky News
well hundreds of Ukrainian children have
been taken from orphanages and
children's homes and transported to
Russia according to the international
Criminal Court's Chief prosecutor but in
Ukraine there are reports of some 16
000 children taken from their homes
Skye's Chief correspondent Stuart Ramsey
and his team have spoken to families in
Kiev and denipro and their battle to get
their children home this is his report
this is the moment ludmiller finally
tracked down and was reunited with her
daughter Nastia after months of
separation
she had traveled thousands of miles
through Russia to Crimea to rescue her
daughter
says she was effectively tricked into
letting her go on a trip organized by
the authorities
is
soil
[Music]
foreign
like thousands of children Nastia joined
what was described as a summer camp but
she says it wasn't that at all
this
is
when Russia paraded a group of Ukrainian
children on a Moscow stage with a
soldier claiming that they were saved
from Ukraine it caused outrage here
Ukraine has been telling the world that
its children were effectively being
kidnapped by Russia to turn them against
their mother country the ICC appears to
agree
president zielinski has been calling for
Action from the ICC since the start of
the year and doubtless he'll be pleased
as will his government about these
latest developments but it's probably
fair to say it'll not make much
difference in the short term that means
that many Ukrainian children will remain
in Russian territory
yeah yeah yeah because say if Ukraine is
an NGO that's dedicated itself to
helping families get their children back
they say Russia had a detailed strategy
and plan to take the children
they thought this through for I don't
know maybe for not even
um
for us who we must look at this from the
perspective of History
so it's nothing new
and this was this whole thing was
prepared and what do they do with
children it's like a part of bigger
policy that's all against Ukraine and
that's been thought about as a proper
plan yeah yeah we stand that it was not
only about
full-scale invasion in 2022 yeah it was
prepared long before this
the exact number of children who have
left Ukraine and may never be seen here
again isn't known
but the ICC moves May one day at least
bring someone responsible to Justice
Stuart Ramsey Sky news Ukraine
hello International Affairs editor
Dominic waghorn is with me now and this
is an extraordinary development in the
war but is it a game changer will it
make anything change at all will there
be a difference I think it's a huge
moment it's we're not going to see as
we've been hearing all day we're not
going to see Vladimir Putin being hauled
off to the Hague I don't think it's
going to have huge impact on him in
terms of in terms of personal
consequences even in terms of his his
ability to travel that may not be as
restricted as as we kind of initially
thought if you look at omail Bashir the
Sudanese indicted leader indicted by the
ICC he was able to travel fairly freely
despite being indicted but it does have
a big impact I think in terms of Putin
standing in the world and Russia's it
makes Putin more of a pariah Russian
more of a pariah it makes it more
isolated and that could impact I think
the support it has if you look at all
those countries have been abstaining in
those U.N votes countries like India a
lot of countries in Africa in the Middle
East they have been doing so because of
a kind of moral ambivalence they've had
about the war they don't like what
Russia is doing but they also they're
not sure about NATO's expansion they've
bought Russia's lies really that this is
all about defending itself against NATO
and those reservations go back to the
Iraq War Kosovo and the rest of it
um I think this now makes it much more
cut and dried you know the ICC is not
NATO it's not a western organization
it's an international organization it
draws its judges from around the world
it is highly respected and therefore I
think branding uh Putin is a suspected
war criminal makes it much harder for
the Russians to try and say to these
potential supporters look whereas
they're as bad as as we are and I think
it encourages them to now come out and
support the west or support Ukraine or
not support Russia and not give Russia
the kind of diplomatic cover they've had
in the U.N but also I think in in terms
of the it has these countries have been
fairly expedient in the way they have
been abstaining in in the UN they've
been worried about which way the war is
going to go hedging their bets this I
think reinforces the impression that
this war is only really going in One
Direction and it's not going to end well
for Vladimir Putin okay Dominic thank
you we shall see what difference this
development makes thank you
new figures out today show that 175
000 procedures and appointments were
canceled due to the three-day Junior
doctor strikes this week the government
and Junior doctors have now agreed to
talk about pay with the hope to put an
end to any further walkouts but while
there is progress the end of industrial
action is still a long way off with more
strikes called today by airport staff
let's take a look at what strike action
we should expect teachers and NHS staff
have called off their strikes but those
are offset by some new announcements of
industrial action further rail strikes
are planned for tomorrow and the end of
the month
driving test examiners are striking on
six days this month and University staff
who are on strike today continue their
industrial action next week
security guards at Heathrow Airport have
announced they will strike for 10 days
over Easter ending on Easter Sunday
and passport office staff will strike
for five weeks from the 3rd of April
[Applause]
30 days but this week's Junior doctor
strike was the most disruptive
industrial action in the NHS yet with
175 000 appointments and operations
canceled
yet after yesterday's 4 billion pound
breakthrough for NHS staff like nurses
the union representing doctors has also
agreed to pay talks it's positive that
the
unions of Mr Barkley have been able to
have talked I do hope that we can work
towards an arrangement of course unions
have had a health care sectors have had
varying levels of real-terms pay cuts so
I hope that he brings us something that
will be acceptable to our members some
argue the government has been canny by
first picking off the Striking workers
most popular with the public in nurses
but even with that proposed pay deal
questions remain because even if union
members vote for it it is not clear how
the government will pay for it to make
that happen something else has to give
it might be that there's cuts to
headcount it might be that there's cuts
to other things like investment in
Digital Services it might mean that they
have to somehow squeeze out some further
efficiency savings at this stage we
don't know
teacher strikes are on pause as the
leaders of England's teaching unions are
now in intensive negotiations with the
government we hope you've missed the
test though tonight they were
tight-lipped
meanwhile the PCS Union has announced
passport workers will soon strike for
five weeks I think the government's
approach has been consistently
disgraceful the Union's boss argues
there are a few reasons to be hopeful
well I think it's looking pretty bleak
at the moment
um I think the common denominator for me
is the government you know we've seen
real progress made in Scotland across
all celsa sectors we've seen progress in
Wales we've seen progress for
firefighters with the English local
authorities but up until yesterday
anywhere where the Westminster
government makes a decision there's been
no progress at all and there's more
misery for Holiday makers on the horizon
with the unite Union announcing 10 days
of industrial action at Heathrow over
Easter
some workers may now have landed a deal
but for others the journey is far from
over Joe Pike Sky News
Paris Hilton has described how she was
taken from her home in the middle of the
night and taken to a facility for
troubled teenagers in America it's an
industry that is estimated to be worth
several billion dollars taking in
thousands of children a year but as
shown an investigation by Sky News it's
a business plagued by allegations and
evidence of neglect and abuse Paris
Hilton was put into one of these
facilities as a teenager she's been
talking to our correspondent Martha
Kellner for
years Paris Hilton kept part of her life
secret but now she's ready to talk about
the trauma that still wakes her up in a
cold sweat I've had
severe nightmares ever since I was 16 of
these people coming in and just taking
me in the middle of the night
the original it girl but behind the
celebrity was the reality of what Paris
Hilton endured for two years at boarding
schools for so-called troubled teens
her parents believed the only way to get
her there was to arrange for her to be
taken by strangers and bundled into the
back of a waiting van
4 30 in the morning two large men came
into my room
shook me out of bed and said do you want
to go the easy way the hard way and they
were holding up handcuffs
and I had no idea what was happening I
thought that I was being kidnapped I
didn't know who these people were
it's hard to believe that that can be
legal isn't it it's hard to believe that
any of this is legal
eventually Paris Hilton ended up here
Provo Canyon school is in the foothills
of Utah's Wasatch mountains inside this
secure compound she describes Life as a
living hell it was almost like they
enjoyed
abusing children it's even hard to
describe because it's like something out
of a horror film they would force
medication on everyone they sent me to
what they call OBS where you're just
locked in this tiny cell with blood
stains on the wall take away all your
clothes and they leave you there for
hours and hours you talk specifically
about being at Provo Canyon school and
you and other female classmates peers
being taken from your beds in the middle
of the night and forced into a different
room to undergo fake gynological
examinations that is sexual abuse isn't
it
it's just
to be treated like a criminal when
you're just a kid
and the strip searches constantly
as an adult now I see that as sexual
abuse here we are at Paris in school in
response to the allegations Provo
Canyon's owners say the school was sold
in 2000 and they can't comment on the
operations or student experience prior
to that time but that they do not
condone or promote any form of abuse
yeah Paris has become a figurehead for a
movement which campaigns to shut down
troubled teen schools Across America
these people need to be held accountable
I know by us continuing to fight this
fight
that we will succeed and they messed
with the wrong girl
listening to her reliving the darkest
moments of her life it is hard to
dispute they did indeed mess with the
wrong girl Martha Kellner Sky News
Beverly Hills
two motions of no confidence have been
tabled against the French government
after president macron pushed a pension
reform through Parliament yesterday
without a vote thousands of people are
now demonstrating on the streets of
Paris for a second day with hundreds of
arrests made our International
correspondent Alex Rossi reports from
Paris
it was another night of protest and
rioting as demonstrators lit fires and
confronted the police in the place de la
Concourse
this Fury here and across France at
president macron's plan to raise the
retirement age from 62 to 64. hello
Henry because even if we're protest they
will just do a 49.3 and there is no
difference between a special
constitutional power yes yes and it's
only here in France so it's very hungry
you feel it's anti-democratic yes where
are very
[Music]
very changed it's really unfair for
everyone a lot of people manifested and
protested already in the streets
pacifically and they don't want to hear
us and now we're going to scream
[Applause]
[Music]
the nation is now braced for much more
of this protesters once again lobbing
missiles at the police
the backdrop to this standoff the lower
house of parliament which the government
bypassed instead using special
Constitutional Powers to force through
the legislation it is difficult to
overstate just how angry people are at
president macron's pension reforms the
big question now is whether or not the
strikes the demonstrations and even the
riots become more frequent in the days
weeks and months to come and bring
paralysis to this country France has
been dealing with rolling strikes and
direct actions for a couple of months
since the plan was announced and perhaps
nothing symbolizes this crisis more than
the bags of uncollected rubbish clogging
up the capital streets
in this country are dignified and
comfortable retirement is seen as an
inalienable right after years of hard
work and it cuts to the core of what it
means to be French
but the government claims with an aging
population reform is unavoidable if the
system is not to buckle and break
more nightly protests are now planned
and the next few days will be a big test
for the government and a nation which is
seething at the prospect of having to
work longer
Alex Rossi Sky News Paris
[Applause]
[Music]
the latest Hearing in Prince Harry's
libel claim against the Publishers of
the mail on Sunday is back in the high
court the Duke of Sussex won the first
part of his legal challenge last year
when a judge ruled that an article
published about his security
Arrangements here in the UK was in fact
defamatory a warning there is Flash
photography from the very start of this
report by our Royal correspondent Laura
bundock
the Duke of Sussex is fighting Fleet
Street and his latest legal battles back
in court a libel claim against the mail
on Sunday over an article last year
about his security the judge already
ruled the story was defamatory but the
case continues and the paper's lawyers
insist they have a strong defense
what the judge is deciding is whether or
not there is any basis for the for the
trial to continue and the defensive
honest opinion is in essence what it
says on the tin to a large extent could
somebody honestly have held the opinion
that was published in in the mail
um based on the facts that were known at
the Time Prince Harry's hatred of
British tabloids is well known in his
Memoir spare he vowed to prove the Press
liars and law Breakers and we're
beginning to see how he's taking on the
tabloids with three more litigations
coming to court soon against the
Publishers of the Sun the mirror and
another case against the Daily Mail all
concerning illegal phone hacking some
people think that phone hacking is old
news but actually there are still
hundreds of cases going through the
court and New Revelations about the
extent of the wrongdoing are being made
such as burglaries being commissioned by
newspaper and also the tapping of
landline cause the libel case here is
about just one story but it symbolizes
something much bigger Harry has the
tabloids in his sights and every day in
court is another sign of his continued
Crusade
members of the royal family usually keep
out of court despite commanding huge
press coverage they'd rather be seen on
official duties but not Harry he's made
it clear his is a mission with the media
which will be he says his life's work
Laura bundock Sky News at the high court
U.S President Joe Biden voiced his
support for the New brexit Deal on trade
in Northern Ireland he made the comment
during a meeting with the Irish Prime
Minister Leo varadka as the two leaders
marked St Patrick's Day in Washington DC
Mr Biden also said he will make a
planned visit to the island of Ireland
soon
prior to spend some time with the Prime
Minister of Great Britain and I've very
much very strongly supported the uh the
Windsor framework which I know you do
too maybe we'll get a chance to talk
about that
and uh for us the 25th anniversary of
the Good Friday agreement
American actor Lance Reddick best known
for his role in The Wire has died age
60. a spokesperson said he passed away
suddenly this morning from natural
causes his Wyatt co-star Wendell Pierce
called Mr Riddick the epitome of
Elegance
a police officer has been found guilty
of gross misconduct for using excessive
force when she repeatedly beat
ex-footballer Dalian Atkinson with her
baton an independent tribunal found that
PC Mary Ellen Beckley Smith acted
wrongly when she hit Mr Atkinson during
an incident in August of 2016.
it was the last day of the Cheltenham
festival today ending with the Gold Cup
Galloping deschan took the prize cheered
on by 70 000 fans Lisa Dowd reports
the odds of an Irish winner on Saint
Patrick's Day are always high at
Cheltenham but the Gold Cup was also a
story of redemption
call townend in the golden brown silks
on board the favorite galapinde shop
emerged from the pack
the seven-year-old had fallen at the
final fence at last year's Festival but
this time no such mistake
on the course and in the bars of
gloucestershire they were invested in
this result
and I just won on the loss the Gold Cup
race most of us back to every single
horse so we kind of had a good chance of
winning some money
all like back in them and we were ready
to go and I think we're probably one of
the loudest um here it's trainer Willie
mullins's third Gold Cup victory in five
years attendances over the week have
been slightly down here at Cheltenham
but the Gold Cup delivered the drama it
so often does and victory for the
favorite means a lot of people heading
home Happy
for those watching it was an
extraordinary ride
just a race with so many stories but in
the middle of it was this incredible
horse Galloping to Charlotte it really
was just a race for everyone and it was
true pure horse racing at its best this
is a horse that showed so much potential
but having won the Irish Gold Cup last
month and now the Gold Cup it's an
almost Flawless season
Lisa Dowd Sky News Cheltenham